William Shakespeare.
Born 1564 in…
You know what?
I am tired of filming against an
amateur-hour lockdown green-screen
in a tiny, boxy, echoey room.
So for the first time,
let's take the Language Files
on the road.
"Go on location, Tom,
it'll look spectacular."
Yeah, maybe it will, but it's also
about two degrees above freezing,
and I'm being pestered occasionally
by some surprisingly aggressive swans.
Anyway! Shakespeare.
Born in 1564 here
in Stratford-Upon-Avon.
Shakespeare’s plays and poetry have
a certain rhythm and feeling to them.
A French-speaking poet could not have written
something that sounds like Shakespeare.
Because the language you speak
affects the poetry and verse
that it’s possible for you to write.
Let’s start with English.
English has what’s called “lexical stress”.
There’s a difference in how we say the noun
“a CON-test”
versus the verb, “to con-TEST”.
Stressed syllables are part of
speech and poetic writing in English,
and if you put the stress on the
wrong syl-LAB-le, it sounds ridi-CU-lous.
...this is not going to be
one continuous take.
There’s a lot of really difficult things
for me to perform in the script.
So there's going to be jump cuts.
Anyway. English also has “prosodic stress”,
which is the difference between:
_I_ want that
I _want_ that
and I want _that_,
which are all different interpretations
of the same three words.
I’m not talking about
that kind of stress here:
I’m talking about lexical stress,
the stress that’s built into
the words that we use.
Stress isn’t normally something you have
to consider too much while writing,
but in English poetry
where meter and timing matter,
you have to be very careful with it.
But I figured Shakespeare would be
quite a dull demonstration to start with,
so instead, how about a less highbrow
bit of poetry, like a limerick.
Not that Shakespeare was originally just highbrow,
but that’s a whole separate issue.
Limericks.
"There once was a man from…"
Well, from where?
In increasing order of rudeness,
he might be from Leeds,
or Madras,
or Nantucket.
But the number of syllables
in those names doesn’t matter:
you just make sure that the
one stressed syllable
is in the right place
and they all sound fine.
But you can’t have: “there once
was a man from Washington”.
It doesn’t quite sound right.
The lexical stress is a little bit early.
And you can’t move that stress later,
because it sounds worse to say
“There once was a man
from Wa-SHING-ton”.
No, the lexical stress is wrong.
For a limerick, the LEXical STRESS
has to LAND on the BEAT.
Now, there is a solution:
“There once was a man…
from Washington”,
but it’s a little bit clunky.
There’s a pause in there.
Compare that to French,
which doesn’t have lexical stress.
Just to be clear, French speakers do
still stress words to emphasise them,
they use prosodic stress,
but that’s it.
In French, by default, stress lands
on the last syllable of an utterance.
So, and this is going to be
really difficult to perform,
I’m not going to attempt a ridiculous
comedy French accent here,
but, if you experi-MENT,
you’ll find you sound much more FRENCH
when you empha-SISE
only the last sylla-BLE.
I think I got that.
Anyway, that means you cannot
have a limerick in French.
The FEEling and SOUND of a LIMerick
reLIES on the LEXical STRESS,
and that doesn’t exist in French.
So why does Shakespeare
sound like Shakespeare?
Well, because: “iAMbic”
AND “pentameter”.
Two words that make a fancy way to say:
Stress every other syllable, in pairs,
with five such pairs in every line you write.
And that was Shakespeare’s style. Well, usually.
He didn’t stick to that for every line.
And if you want to sound
like him, that’s how.
“If MU-sic BE the FOOD
of LOVE, play ON.”
The reason Shakespeare sounds
like Shakespeare is:
he wrote in rhythm, mostly.
Which is nice.
But if you’re translating that to French,
well,
French can’t do that.
Yes, there are all sorts of exceptions
for poetic reasons,
the same as English can break its own
rules sometimes, but in gener-AL:
French stress SITS
at the end of the utter-ANCE.
You can translate Romeo and Juliet’s words
and sentences and meanings into French, sure...
but it won’t sound like Shakespeare.
It can’t sound like Shakespeare.
So instead, some translators use an
equivalent French form: the alexandrine.
Twelve syllables per line,
broken into two parts.
And it should also rhyme.
Stress the end of each half.
This is why poetry in translation often
doesn’t sound right, or even poetic:
because you need to translate
not just the words,
but the style and the stress patterns as well.
Yes, you can adapt the style,
play with it a bit,
English does have an alexandrine form,
but it doesn’t work in quite the
same way as the original French.
And French does not work
in iambic pentameter.
Are there French poets with the same skills
of wordplay and drama that Shakespeare had?
Of course. But they could
NE-ver sound like Will.
There’s more about translating texts, including
Old English becoming very modern English,
in my co-author Gretchen McCulloch’s
podcast Lingthusiasm.
There’s a link on screen
or in the description.